Енергетика за всі 30 років незалежності країни була основним джерелом
надприбутків українських олігархів. Вони зробили свої мільярдні статки саме завдяки
газу, генерації тепла та електрики.
Тому тривалий час лобіювали своїх кандидатур на посаду міністра енергетики України, який би їм "не заважав".
З 1 серпня минулого року в Україні формально запрацював ринок газу для населення.
Втім, 70 відсотків роздрібного ринку газу і надалі залишаються за облгазами,
які входять до Регіональної газової компанії олігарха Дмитра Фірташа.
НАК "Нафтогаз України" має 7 відсотків, а решта - дрібні гравці з частками до 2 відсотків.
За час лібералізації газового ринку ліцензії отримали кілька сотень приватних газових постачальників,
але де-факто на українському ринку побутових споживачів працює лише близько пів сотні компаній.
У споживачів з’явилася альтернатива: обрати того газопостачальника,
який пропонує більш прийнятні умови і змінити постачальника газу за спрощеною процедурою.
Але, за розповідями багатьох споживачів, фактичні монополісти - облгази -
тиснуть на людей, зокрема раптово виявляють невідповідність нормам газового обладнання,
нараховують сумнівні борги або залякують відключенням газу.
Згідно з оновленим рейтингом найбагатших людей України від Forbes, очолює список
Рінат Ахметов зі статками понад 7 з половиною мільярдів доларів.
Показово, що порівняно з минулорічним рейтингом його капітал збільшився у два з поливною рази.
Холдинг ДТЕК, що належить Рінату Ахметову, за експертними оцінками,
контролює 90 відсотків видобутку енергетичного вугілля та 70 відсотків усіх теплоелектростанцій.
У "Центренерго", а це єдина компанія теплової генерації в Україні, яка досі належить державі
- 18 відсотків. І в приватної "Донбасенерго" - 10 відсотків.
Аналітики енергоринку закидають Ахметову, що він пролобіював відключення енергоблоків
на українських атомних електростанціях минулого року, що сприяло попиту на енергію
від теплових і сонячних електростанцій, які, власне, належать олігарху.
Один кіловат від АЕС коштує приблизно пів гривні, тоді як від ТЕС - півтори і до 5 гривень від сонячної.
Лідером у галузі відновлюваних джерел енергії в Україні також є підрозділ ДТЕК Ріната Ахметова.
Його вітроелектростанції та сонячні електростанції контролюють 17 відсотків ринку.
На другому місці китайська компанія CNBM. У неї 12 відсотків.
На третьому - шведські бізнесмени Карл Стурен та Йохан Боден з 9 відсотками.
Далі йдуть інші приватні власники, в кожного з яких по декілька відсотків.
Торік загальна потужність відновлюваної електроенергетики в Україні зросла на 22 відсотки.
Після Німеччини та Іспанії Україна стала третьою у Європі за встановленими
потужностями сонячних електростанцій.
Однак у загальному енерговиробництві в Україні частка "зеленої" енергії
все ще відносно незначна - за даними Держенергоефективності, до 10 відсотків.
З одного боку, інвестиції в "зелену" енергетику та її екологічність - це добре.
А з іншого боку, "зелені" тарифи в Україні все ще необґрунтовано одні з найвищих у Європі.
Понад 10 років тому їх запровадили фактично для заробітку близьких соратників Януковича
- братів Клюєвих, які звели сонячні електростанції на півдні України.
Нині ж через стрімкий розвиток відновлюваної енергетики грошей на дотації катастрофічно не вистачає -
у держави мільярдні борги, які тягнуть за собою підвищення тарифів для населення.
У Євросоюзі водень оголошено енергоносієм майбутнього.
За три роки у ЄС його щорічне виробництво планується довести до одного мільйона тонн.
Це - шанс для України. Зокрема і для української ГТС, яка могла б транспортувати водневі суміші в Європу.
Приміром, у разі, якщо Росія відмовиться від транспортування свого газу територією України.
За словами експертів, у далекій перспективі, якби вдалося налагодити
систему постачання водню для комунальних систем, можна було б відмовитися
від централізованого опалення, яке працює на природному газі.
Українські олігархи до цього вже готуються і поволі "перевзуваються" з вугілля
та інших "брудних" джерел енергії на "зелений" водень.
Зокрема, у стадії підготовки пілотний проєкт з водневого виробництва
на металургійному заводі в Маріуполі за участі ДТЕК Ріната Ахметова
та німецького Siemens Energy.
А компанія РГК Дмитра Фірташа, теж проводить водневі експерименти
у кількох регіонах України, як та в яких пропорціях можна було б постачати водень українськими трубами.
Тож, є загроза, що в майбутньому ринок водню, як до того й інші сектори енергетики,
опиниться повністю в руках олігархів.
Джерела енергії в Україні змінюються, а ті, хто їх контролює - ні.